جاكيشنز الا لم يكن هناك اعتراض
تم اتخاذ هذا القرار
للانتقال الى الفقره السابعه التي تتعلق
بالاضرار بسبب التغير المناخير اللجنه
التنفيذيه همم التي وعدت بالدوره
السابعه عشر والوضعات اليات اللي تكون
للمؤتمر والاطراف
باريس في
25 و26 كان هناك دراسه
صلاحيات الالقاب بما في ذلك اللجنه
تنفيذيه في الدوره 26 كان هناك همم فقرات
لدراسه همم
حكما سيستمر ذلك
الدوره 27 الان اعين رئيس اللي
او وارحه ولا صلاحيات ونفوذ كوب حول هذه
الفقره
وان لم يكن هناك اعتراض اذا اتخذنا هذا
القرار واتفقنا
سيتم اعتمادا والان ادعوكم للانتقال
للفقرات الثامنه المتعلقه بالتمويل بما
فيها الفقرات من الف الى فاء وقبل
الانتقال الى المواد الفرعيه
وشيروا الى الفقره
التاليه التي تشمل القائمه المراجعه
ليكون هناك ملحقات لهذه الفقرات
وهناك التمويل طويل
اللجنه الماليه
كان هناك تقرير حول
تقدم
وكانت تخسيس مليار دولار ثانويه
اخذين بالاعتبار
خطا الماليه
للتنفيذ وكذلك طلبه في الدوره السادسه
والعشرين ان تواصل اللجنه عملها وتعريفها
للتمويل المناخي واتخاذ اجراءات اخرى
للملاحقات
المسائل المرتبطه بالفقره الثانيه من
اتفاقيه باريس بالاشاره الى البنت
نشكر
الرئاسه المشتركه للاساسيه
من النساء
والسيد من همم جنوب افريقيا
للقياده والعمل الذي قاموا فيه هذا العام
اما بالنسبه لتقرير تقدم ال ال ودى
هناك همم
[موسيقى]
100 مليار دولار كانت مخصصه سنويا
لجمع المعلومات واا
تعريفه تمويل المناخير
والتقرير اشار الى تعبئه مشتركه لمئه
مليار دولار سنويا لمعالجه وتلبيات
احتياجات الدول الناميه واتخذت اجراءات
الحد من
النتائج او الاضرار المناخيه وكذلك ضمن
للشفافيه اما بالبند همم
المتعلق باللجنه التمويل فقد طلبت الدوره
السادسه والعشرين ان يتم تنظيم الجزء
الثاني من منتدى التمويل
لحلول مبنيه على البيئه في 2022 وان يتم
الافاده في 27 الدوره 27 همم حول كل الخطط
التي كان في دهان في الدوره السادسه
والعشرين كانت هناك دراسه
لاعمال ووظائف الاسياف
وتم
تم الاستمرار بالمفاوضات حتى واو النقاشات
حتى 27
او الدوره السابعه والعشرين وكان هناك
اعمال
اضافيه تم اتخاذها لدراسه
الموارد التمويل وكذلك الاشاره همم اتفاق
اتفاقيه باريس ودراسه التقارير
اللجنه الماليه الاسياف وكذلك مراجعه
اعمال اللجنه بما فيتعلق
البنود 8 سي
حول الارشادات لصندوق تمويل المناخي فقط
تم التوفير الارشادات للجنسياف حول سياسات
والاولويات
الصلاحيه
او اخذها بالاعتبار
ايضا كان هناك اطراف
اليات الماليه والجمع المعلومات وتحليل
تقديمات الدول وفقا
للمسوده التي تم تقديمها من تقرير الاسياف
والتقرير السنوي للعمليات
في سجل النمر
من فرنسا
كالرئيسين المشتركين لمجلس الجنسي
في البند ثمانيه حول توفير تسهيلات
والارشادات
للمرافق المناخيه فاننا ندعوا لتوفير
الارشادات حول سياسات والاولويات
والشرح صلاحيات التي يجب اخذها بالاعتبار
التقرير السنوي للجيه
ومسوده الارشادات
للهيئات العامله حول الاهليه همم اليه
الاطراف الميثره
واللجنه التمويل وتحليل وتحليل
عاوزين 24
حول الارشادات التي وضعت في 2022
والتقرير السنوي لعمليات سجل
راس رئيس
السيد كارلوس
والامانه العامه
لجياف
وبالنسبه للبند ثمانيه
[موسيقى]
اف ايه فكرنا باضافتها
لدراسه الفقدان والاضرار بسبب التغير
المناخي والتركيز على الخسائر والاضرار
الى
ااا كيفيه التعامل مع هذه الماده بالنسبه
للتمانيه ااه
لرئاسه المجموعه المخصصه لدراسه هذه
الجزئيه
واما الثانيه في مسلسل
من اليابان
سيكون لديهم مجموعه اتصال للدراسه هذه
البنود اما في 8 اي فريق
يكون رئيسا المشتركين لهذه المجموعه
المختلطه
خوليو كورنادو من شيلي وارسله من ون بيس
من المانيا
سيكونوا ميسرين
للمشاورات الخاصه بدراسات هذه البند
بما انه لا يوجد اعتراض على ما ذكر
فقد تم اعتماد القرار
17 المتعلقه
مسائل الماليه
وفي
الدوره السادسه والعشرين لم يتم التوصل
الى الاتفاق حول هذه هذه الماده
وبالتالي فان هذه
همم
ثم اخذها في الجدول الاعمال هذه الدوره
الدوره 27 وبالتالي سيكون رئيس
جلسه او
المجموعه مختصه بدراسه هذه الماده وحتى لا
يوجد تراث فانه تم اعتماد هذا القرار
الوفود الكرام هذا ياخذ بناء
لانهاء نهايه الاجتماع الاول في هذا
المؤتمر والان سنرفع الجلسه
وان
اتقي لاحقا بعد
الجلسه الافتتاحيه وسيكون هناك الهيئه
المختلفه
وفرق العمل ستلتقي والمراقبين ايضا ان لم
يكن لديكم اعتراض فا نرفع هذه الجلسه
[تصفيق]
فعاليات القمه قمه المناخ على 20 في شرم
الشيخ التي يفتتحت كما تابعنا
بكلمه لرئيس القمه السادسه والعشرين ثم
تسليم رئاسه هذه الدوره الى الوزير سامح
شكري وزير الخارجيه المصري الذي تحدث الان
المتعلقه بالشؤون التنظيميه سننتقل الى
همم
وتبني الاجنده فبالتالي تم تبني الاجنده
جاكي شان
اعتماد هذا القرار
اصدقائي
[موسيقى]
نبدا بالانتقال الى توسي وهي
الاجراءات التنظيميه للقاء ساقترح فيه
دراسه همم
الرابعه وهي الافاده من
الاطراف المعنيه
والجمع السنوي
والمحاسبه
لفتره المسؤوليه الثانيه
201920 و 21 و22
وبالتالي سيتم اتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه
وفقا لتوصيات
الهيئات المعنيه والبندق
او التعامل مع المسائل المناخيه تمام
اتفاق عليه وهناك ايضا اجراءات
الاستجابه وهناك المؤسسات
الماليه هذه
المواد ستكون
تحت مسؤوليه الهيئات المهنيات لتركز وتحول
التوصل الى قرارات فيما يتعلق اما البنت
اربع سنين وتاريخ انهاء تقرير مراجعه
الخبراء
الثانيه
او 16
الى الهيئه في الجلسه السادسه والخمسين
انه عملهم واا التخلوق قرار ابشر ابشر
وسيتم الاتفاق عليه في نهايه الجلسه
وخلال الجلسه الاولى الافتتاحيه فقد
اقترحت ااا دراسه هذه المواد وان يكون
اتجاه المتبعه في مؤتمر
القرارات
التي اعتمدت بالفقرات السابقه
وكبراند فرنساوي
مره ثانيه مع اللجنه وسنرى الاستنتاجات
وما هي
قراراتهم وفي بحيث لا يوجد اي اعتراض فقد
تم اعتماد هذه المدى الان ادعوا
الكلمات
شكرا لكم
وهذه العمليه هي مساله
تتطلب منا تعاون دوليه وعلى مدى ثمانيه
سنوات
ولكن كنا نعمل بهذا الاتجاه لكن في الشهر
اشهر الثمانيه الاخيره
من
عدوان الروسيه على اوكرانيا وهذه الحرب في
وسط اوروبا وهي تهدد الشعب الاوكراني
واقتصاده
والهويه الاوكرانيه هذه الحرب
لكل اوروبا والعالم باكمله وهذا الاحتلال
المؤقت لي
همم اراد الاوكراني لا يؤكد مساله
اهميه التقارير وجمع المعلومات نحن نؤكد
خلقنا حول
مصداقيه المعلومات التي يتم جمعها وان
هذه المساله ذات اهميه الكبرى وفي البرد
الف وباءنا اوكرانيا ترحب باقتراح الرئاسه
ان ننقل الدراسه هذه الى الجلسه القادمه
شكرا لكم
نشكر مندوبه اوكرانيا
الخامسه في الاجنده حول الاليات
والربما نشير الى التقرير السنوي
التقينا الاسبوع الماضي
عمر قلقاسه
على قيادته والاعضاء
مجلس على عملهم داؤوب واقترح اقامه مجموعه
اتصال خاصه بهذه الماده للرئها اليابان
فقط
الاكشن
المدى السادسه عراقيه
الفتى اللي الموارد لهذا العام
ونشكر وناخذ توصيات اللجنه الاشرفيه حول
متابعه
اعمالها تحت
المشاورات الرئاسه انهم يكون لديكم اعتراض
فقد تم اعتماد ذلك
انتخاب الاعضاء والاعضاء البدلاء الجلسه
نهائي نهائي
قضايا المتعلقه لصندوق
مساء المناخيه ونعود الى الوثيقه
لعام 2022 على 4 على 1000 6
وملحقاتها
السيد توفيق من السعوديه
لاقامات لجنه اتصال لدراسه هذه
الجزئيه برئاسه سبايدر مان
بما انه لا يوجد اعتراض انني اعطي الكلمه
لللجنه
ميرسي ميرسي شكرا
[موسيقى]
حيث كان رئيس القمه 27 وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري
يعدد البنود التي تم الاتفاق عليها ضمن
جدول
الاعمال
للجلسه الاولى المقرر لهذه القمه
تبعنا معكم مجموعه من الجنود التي اتفق
عليها او اتفقت عليها اللجان العامله
المنظمه لقمه المناخ والتي تستمر حتى يوم
الثامن عشر من نوفمبر الجاري وتوقع ان
تشهد همم هذه القمه وكما نشاهد ربما
مشاركه واسعه همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي وممثلي المنظمات الدوليه
والاقليميه المعنيه بشئون المناخ